[Música]
jornada de elecciones estatales en
México más de 15 millones de personas
están habilitadas para elegir gobernador
en los estados de Coahuila y México este
último el más poblado del país Los
comicios representan una medición de
fuerzas de Cara a las presidenciales de
combatientes rusos proucranianos afirman
que están avanzando en las afueras de la
región rusa de vélgorón cuyo gobernador
aseguró que batallan contra un grupo al
que definió como saboteadores ucranianos
y en Ucrania Rusia lanzó una oleada de
ataques aéreos durante la madrugada del
domingo y este domingo se cumplen 34
años de la matanza de Diana men cuando
miles de estudiantes chinos que
reclamaban más democracia en 1989 fueron
Víctimas de una brutal represión que
dejó un número aún desconocido de
muertos que podrían oscilar entre
cientos y miles en Hong Kong se
registraron arrestos a varias personas
que conme moraron la fecha
muy buenos días y muy bienvenidos una
nueva emisión informativa de Franz 24 en
español que comenzamos en México avanzan
allí las elecciones estatales en los
estados de Coahuila y México este último
el más poblado de todo el país más de 15
millones de personas están habilitadas
para elegir gobernadores en unos
comicios que servirán para marcar el
pulso político por la carrera hacia la
presidencia en 2024 en France 24
dialogamos con Francisco Javier jaro
doctor en ciencias políticas y
relaciones internacionales acerca del
escenario que proyectaron algunos
sondeos de opinión con una posible
derrota del pri en el Estado de México
Bueno pues Por una parte
Posiblemente sea la casi extinción
institucional del del pri lo que no Por
lo menos el estado de México lo que no
quiere decir que desaparezcan las
fuerzas que conforman el pri que algunas
de ellas son muy fuertes principalmente
el estado de México y va a ser o bien
que se fortalezca la alianza
fundamentalmente entre el pri Y el pan o
se rompa y cada quien siga su camino de
cualquiera de cualquier forma sea cual
sea la opción es muy complicado para
para estas fuerzas ahora
enfrentarse a morena tienen una gran
debilidad institucional discursiva la
ausencia de una personalidad que los
unifique que atraiga al futuro al futuro
votante del año próximo
avanzamos ahora con información sobre la
guerra en Ucrania combatientes rusos
pro- ucranianos aseguran que están
avanzando en las afueras de la región
rusa de velgorot fronteriza con Ucrania
esto luego de que advirtieran que tienen
cautivos a dos soldados rusos y
ofrecieran intercambiarlos por una
reunión con el gobernador regional quien
Ya dijo estar dispuesto a juntarse con
el grupo si es que los cautivos se
encuentran con vida el funcionario
reportó además un nuevo estallido de
combates cerca de la frontera donde
aseguró que batallan contra un grupo al
que definió como saboteadores ucranianos
mientras en territorio ucraniano Rusia
lanzó una oleada de ataques aéreos
durante la madrugada del domingo todos
los detalles en este informe
otra noche de angustia para el pueblo de
kiev a las primeras horas del domingo Se
oyeron varias explosiones en la región
durante ataques con drones y misiles
según las autoridades la defensa aérea
destruyó todo lo que se dirigía hacia la
capital ucraniana en un perímetro en las
últimas semanas los ataques rusos sobre
el país se han intensificado el sábado
la ciudad de libro en el centro del país
fue atacada según el presidente de
Ucrania no fue alcanzada una zona
Residencial matando a una niña hiriendo
a 22 personas los rusos atacaron la
ciudad atacaron entre dos edificios de
residenciales de dos plantas por
desgracia hay gente bajo los escombrosos
también aumentan los ataques al otro
lado de la frontera en la región rusa de
belgoraza el gobernador local afirmó que
los bombardeos ucranianos mataron a dos
personas el sábado
los pueblos en primer lugar al distrito
de ácido bombardeado
que escuchen la posición de los
autoridades y abandonen temporalmente
sus hogares para salvaguardar lo más
importante su vida y la de sus allegados
por su parte quien dijo que esos ataques
fueron llevados a Cabo por paramilitares
rusos Opuestos a Moscú
avanzamos con más noticias en 24 en
español El opositor a Vladimir Putin
alexei navany celebrará este domingo sus
47 años y lo hará en una prisión de alta
seguridad de rusa acusado de
malversación y desacato a un tribunal y
en medio de un nuevo proceso por
supuesta incitación al extremismo sus
seguidores acusan al Estado ruso de
persecución los detalles en el informe
de Rodrigo sedano
Estas son las últimas imágenes en
público de alexei navaly se vieron el 31
de mayo durante un juicio aplazado que
podría dejarlo décadas en prisión este
domingo el Preso político más famoso de
Rusia celebra su cumpleaños en una
prisión de alta seguridad a 250
kilómetros de Moscú sus colaboradores
denuncian que en ocasiones es enviado a
una celda de castigo similar a esta que
instalaron el pasado enero frente a la
embajada rusa en Berlín
hemos visto que Alexa es enviado a esta
celda cada vez que habla en contra de la
guerra aprovecha las audiencias para
alzar la voz contra la guerra y cada vez
que lo hace es castigado
naval ni está en prisión desde 2021 tras
haber sido inhabilitado como político y
denunciar su envenenamiento en 2020 la
condena se alargó en 2022 en medio de
denuncias de falsedad
Por supuesto que apelaremos contra El
veredicto Tan pronto como lo recibamos
presentaremos quejas el 6 de junio
tendrá lugar finalmente el juicio por
extremismo la justicia acusa al líder
opositor y a su fondo de lucha contra la
corrupción de financiar e instigar
acciones extremistas naval ni su equipo
aseguran no conocer exactamente Cuáles
son los cargos
Aunque por el tamaño de los volúmenes
está claro que soy un delincuente
sofisticado y persistente es imposible
saber de qué se me acusa exactamente soy
un hombre corriente al que se le entrega
un acta de acusación y se le dice que se
siente a leerla entre tanto este domingo
sus seguidores convocaron una jornada
mundial en apoyo a navalni será la
típica forma en que celebren su
cumpleaños en su nombre y en otras
noticias el secretario general de la
otan hablamos por supuesto
se reunió este domingo con el presidente
de Turquía Receta y lo hicieron para
discutir la candidatura de Suecia para
unirse a la alianza militar una adhesión
a la cual ankara sea opuesto y ha
planteado objeciones y condiciones Como
por ejemplo la extradición de militantes
kurdos que Turquía considera terroristas
no obstante el líder de la alianza se
mostró optimista sobre el proceso de
adhesión escuchemos lo que dijo
presidente erdogan y yo acordamos hoy
que el mecanismo conjunto permanente
debería reunirse nuevamente en la semana
que comienza el 12 de junio la membresía
hará que Suecia sea más segura pero
también la otan y Turquía serán más
fuertes espero finalizar la adhesión de
Suecia lo antes posible
Mientras tanto en estocolmo
manifestantes salieron a las calles este
domingo para protestar contra el
presidente Turco receta Hernán y en
rechazo a la adhesión de Suecia a la
otan con consignas como no a la otan no
a las leyes de erdoan en Suecia cientos
de personas entre ellas integrantes de
agrupaciones de izquierda y también
simpatizantes del pk.k el partido de los
trabajadores del kurdistán rechazaron la
nueva legislación antiterrorista de
Suecia que prohíbe las actividades
vinculadas a grupos extremistas entre
los que incluye al pkk como lo exige de
Turquía algo que los manifestantes
consideran una restricción a la libertad
de expresión
y este domingo se están cumpliendo 34
años de la masacre de tianan Man que
toma su nombre de la plaza de Beijing
donde cientos de miles de estudiantes
chinos protestaron por más democracia
más libertad y más justicia social en el
año 1989 y la represión fue brutal con
un saldo de víctimas mortales todavía
desconocido pero que podría oscilar
entre cientos y miles de personas y Su
recuerdo ha sido censurado en China
desde aquel momento en Hong Kong que en
teoría goza de más libertades varias
personas que conmemoraron el
acontecimiento fueron detenidas desde
ayer tenemos los detalles en este
informe
frente a la puerta de la paz celestial
otianan men en chino la vida continua el
domingo 4 de junio no había nada que
indicará que ese era el lugar 34 años
antes donde miles de estudiantes chinos
exigiendo un mayor democracia y Justicia
social Fueron tiroteados por el ejército
el gobierno chino ya ha llegado a una
conclusión Clara sobre la agitación
política de los años 80 y ningún intento
de desprestigiar a China e interferir en
sus asuntos internos con este asunto
tendrá éxito el nombre del principio un
país dos sistemas Hong Kong fue durante
décadas el último lugar de China donde
se toleraban las conmemoraciones de
Chana Pero eso cambió en 2020 cuando
Beijing impuso una ley de seguridad
nacional para reforzar su control sobre
la ciudad antes semiautónoma este año la
Plaza Victoria de Hong Kong donde se
celebraban antes las conmemoraciones
haitiana men está ocupada por una feria
dedicada a la cocina tradicional China
creo que es muy bueno porque en el
pasado este lugar estaba ocupado por
otros pero ahora lo hemos tomado
nosotros esto ilustra la prosperidad de
nuestro país y de Hong Kong
han sido retirados de los espacios
públicos y el domingo varias
personalidades prodemocráticas entre
ellas la líder de un importante partido
de la oposición fueron detenidas en Hong
Kong como en el resto de China es
imposible difundir estas imágenes del 4
de junio de 1999 34 años después el
número de víctimas de la represión al
movimiento estudiantil en la plaza de
janetment sigue siendo desconocido
avanzamos con noticias hacíamos Ahora
hasta India Por qué las investigaciones
sobre las causas que provocaron el
accidente de tren continúan informes que
citan a funcionarios ferroviarios
argumentan que un error en la
materialización podría haber sido la
causa de esta tragedia recordemos que el
número de víctimas mortales es Al
momento de al menos 288 personas
mientras que cerca de 900 heridos fueron
trasladados a hospitales más detalles a
continuación
en India los trabajos para levantar a
los escombros del accidente de tren
sucedido el viernes por la noche en el
estado de odicha continúan después de
que las autoridades dijeran que las
operaciones de búsqueda y rescate habían
concluido el Primer Ministro narendra
modi quien visitó el lugar el sábado
declaró que quienquiera que sea señalado
culpable recibirá el castigo más
estricto
entendemos que este tipo de
investigación debe realizarse de manera
rápida y Esperamos que en los próximos
15 o 20 días esté listo el informe
Este es el tercer accidente de tren más
mortífero de la historia de la India y
el peor en cuanto a números de
fallecidos desde 1995 se espera que
aumente el número de víctimas mortales
centenares de personas se reportaron
heridas muchas de ellas de gravedad
cuando se produjo el accidente el tren
Se incendió nadie pudo salvarse algunos
consiguieron salir otros huyeron las
cercanías del sitio de la tragedia se
transformó en un lugar de homenajes a
las víctimas con flores y velas
encendidas en memoria de ellas un
artista de arena esculpió en una playa
una obra que representa el accidente una
manera muy particular de abogar por la
pronta recuperación de los
sobrevivientes
y para finalizar información deportiva
Leo Messi jugó ayer su último partido
con el París Saint Germain con una
derrota en casa por tres a dos contra
crackmore el psg anunció que el Astro
argentino no prolongará su contrato que
termina este mes luego de dos temporadas
en la capital francesa veamos el informe
su nombre sigue brillando en la camiseta
del psg pero para Lionel Messi su
Aventura Parisina llegó al final tras
dos años complicados el Astro argentino
abandonó el club después de la derrota
en el parque de Los Príncipes el sábado
donde volvió a ser silbado
incomprensible para el entrenador del
psg
me parecen muy duros como el del resto
de la temporada ha tenido periodos
buenos y periodos no tan buenos sigue
siendo un gran profesional es el mejor
jugador de la historia del fútbol tiene
unas estadísticas interesantes en una
temporada en la que ha jugado mucho
mucho
con 16 goles y 16 asistencias Lionel
Messi es el mejor pasador de la liga
francesa esta temporada pero las
cualidades técnicas del siete veces
ganador del Balón de oro no bastaron
para impulsar al psg a lo más alto de la
tabla fue eliminado dos veces de la Liga
de Campeones en octavos de final Aunque
la aventura de Messi en el psg ha sido
un éxito en términos de reputación del
Club en el extranjero Y para ventas de
camisetas los aficionados parisinos han
criticado su actitud una cierta
despreocupación y falta de cercanía con
el público una versión que se por su
reciente viaje no autorizado Arabia
Saudita
no lo lamentaremos en términos de
esfuerzo sobre el terreno de juego y
demás pero no creo que sea lo que el psg
necesitaba es cierto que vende camisetas
Mira otra camiseta pero sobre el terreno
de juego no es necesariamente el perfil
que necesitamos
un ambiente que contrasta al de hace dos
años aclamado a su llegada a París
Lionel Messi Busca ahora una salida Un
improbable regreso a Cataluña quizás o
un exilio Dorado en Arabia Saudita o
Florida con el Inter de Miami
llegamos al final de esta emisión
informativa Recuerden que pueden ampliar
estas noticias y conocer muchas más en
France 24.com Gracias por acompañarnos
sigan junto a nosotros
[Música]